انه وقت الظهيره وقد حانت موت الطعام 500
طالب في هذه المدرسه على موعد يومي مع
وجبه غداء تقدم لهم مجانا ضمن برنامج
التغذيه المدرسيه التابعي لاداره العاصمه
اديس ابابا وهو برنامج يستهدف المدارس
الحكوميه التي ينتمي اغلب طلابها الى اسر
منخفضه
من البرنامج ويحصلون على وجبتين يوميا وقد
حصد البرنامج جائزه لتطبيقه معايير
الاستدامه والتاثير والحوكمه
يابسره وشقيقته هيرميلا من الذين حضروا
بفرصه جديده بفضلها هذا البرنامج حيث كادت
والدتهما ان تتوقف عن ارسالهما الى
المدرسه
والادوات الدراسيه
ورفع مستوى ادراك وتفاعلهم في الفصول وهو
ما زاد من نمو مهم المعرفه
برنامج التغذيه المدرسيه ساهم في تقويه
الاداء التعليميه للطلاب وعزز تحصيلهم
الاكاديمي حسب دراسه علميه ميدانيه
ان برنامج التغذيه المدرسيه اداه للحمايه
الاجتماعيه
لمساهمته في الحد من سوء التغذيه بين
الطلاب ولضمان النظام التعليمي فعال من
حيث الاستيعاب والتاثير حسن الرزاق
الجزيره اديس ابابا